diese studie macht wirklich gänsehaut
laut einem internationalen
forschungsteam stehen unsere ökosysteme
kurz vor einem katastrophalen
zusammenbruch demnach wird es in 100
jahren gar keine insekten mehr auf der
erde geben und das bedeutet langfristig
wohl das ende für uns alle in diesem
zusammenhang wird auch das sechste
massensterben genannt auslöser dafür
sind wir menschen warum wir wie ein
heftiger ist soeben einen schlag sind
kriegs umsätzen fiction
hier gibt es täglich spannende science
videos abonnierte kanal nur dann
verpasst ihr nichts herzlich willkommen
erstmal zum anfang möchte ich mich ins
zeug legen für alle heldinnen und helden
die aufstehen gegen den klimawandel
denn ihr seid tatsächlich heldinnen und
helden eben gegensatz zu vielen
vermeintlichen erwachsenen und ich muss
mich für meine generation hier
entschuldigen dass sie trotz eindeutiger
wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse nicht die
konsequenzen zieht und deshalb muss man
euch ganz fraglos unterstützen denn hier
geht es nicht um politik was alle
nationen ja auch bestätigen sie sind
sich ja einer meinung dass hier
gehandelt werden muss aber sie tun es
nicht bzw zu langsam und erfüllen nicht
mal ihre eigenen zusagen sowie die
bundesrepublik deutschland die unter
anderem arbeitsplätze als grund angibt
euch oder eure nachkommen umzubringen da
muss man schon sagen dass das schäbig
ist ich kann also nur jeden und jede
dazu auffordern am 15 märz auf die
weltweite demo in eurer stadt zu gehen
und den politikern und politikerinnen zu
zeigen dass sie sich zu mördern machen
wenn sie nicht zumindest ihre eigenen
beschlüsse umsetzen
ihr habt recht heldinnen und helden ich
bin dabei und ihr auch zum thema schon
einige frühere studien hatten eindeutige
hinweise darauf gegeben dass es immer
weniger insekten gibt vor allem auch in
deutschland schuld daran sind unter
anderem der starke einsatz von
pestiziden die intensive landwirtschaft
und der klimawandel doch eine aktuelle
studie bringt es jetzt knallhart auf den
tisch demnach ist das insekten sterben
ein gigantisches problem und zwar
weltweit die gesamtmasse aller insekten
auf der erde singt demnach jährlich um
zweieinhalb prozent so war es zumindest
in den letzten 25 bis 30 jahren sollte
dieser trend anhalten hätte dies ein
katastrophales ende dazu francisco
sanchez bio
einer der beteiligten forscher in zehn
jahren werden wir ein viertel weniger
haben in 50 jahren ist noch die hälfte
übrig von den 100 jahren werden wir gar
keine mehr haben
nach angaben der studie ist die
sogenannte extraktions rate der begriff
es funktion meint so viel wie aussterben
acht mal höher als bei säugetieren
reptilien und vögeln diese
beunruhigenden erkenntnisse beruhen auf
der analyse von insgesamt 73 berichten
aus der vergangenheit die sich bereits
mit dem rückgang von insekten
populationen weltweit beschäftigt haben
die aktuelle studie macht noch einmal
ganz klar deutlich das ganze ist ein
großes ein großes weltweites problem vor
allem verschiedene arten von bienen sind
dabei für immer zu verschwinden und zwar
vor allem in nordamerika dänemark und
großbritannien betroffen sind aber auch
schmetterlinge und motten in england
beispielsweise gab es zwischen 2000 und
2009 einen rückgang der
schmetterlingsarten auf
landwirtschaftlich genutzten flächen um
58 prozent
auch die anzahl der hummel arten ist
beispielsweise in oklahoma von 1949 bis
2013 um die hälfte gesunken
ähnlich bei den bienen da ist auch ein
krasser rückgang zu verzeichnen während
es 1947 noch sechs millionen honigbienen
kolonien in den usa gab sind es jetzt
nur noch 2,5 millionen und das
aussterben der insekten hat
weitreichende folgen für das gesamte
leben auf der erde
die studie spricht von einem
katastrophalen zusammenbruch der
ökosysteme
falls das sterben der insekten nicht
gestoppt wird wird dies katastrophale
folgen sowohl für die ökosysteme des
planeten als auch für das überleben der
menschheit haben so der forscher sanchez
bio
denn klar ist insekten nehmen eine enorm
wichtige rolle ein als nahrung für
andere lebewesen als bestäuber und
außerdem als nährstoff recycler ein
dramatisches problem resultiere daraus
vor allem für vögel fische amphibien und
reptilien die sich von insekten ernähren
aber auch unsere nahrungsquellen könnten
durch den rückgang der insekten knapp
werden schließlich übernehmen bienen und
schmetterlinge als bestäuber eine
wichtige funktion für das wachstum von
gemüse und früchten in diesem
zusammenhang ist auch vom sogenannten
sechsten massensterben auf der er die
die rede
ein forschungsteam von der universität
mexiko und der stanford university hatte
vor zwei jahren
2017 eine studie veröffentlicht nach der
75 prozent aller spezies in den nächsten
jahrhunderten von der erde verschwinden
werden in ihren untersuchungen kam
heraus dass die populationen von
insgesamt 27.000 600 arten an vögeln
reptilien amphibien und säugetieren
kontinuierlich abnehmen dazu die studie
das sechste massensterben der rwe ist
ernster als anfangs gedacht es geht
etwas großes vor nicht der begriff sagt
es schon auch in früheren zeiten gab es
massive artensterben auf der erde die
ursachen damals waren aber eiszeiten
oder aktuellen einschläge und genau das
ist der große unterschied an dem aktuell
stattfindenden massensterben sind einzig
und allein wir menschen schuld wir die
menschheit verhalten uns also gerade wie
ein absolut katastrophaler riesiger
asteroideneinschlag das ist wirklich
schlimm
laut sánchez ballo bewirkt vor allem
eine bestimmte sache das aussterbende
insekten die hauptursache für den
rückgang ist die intensive
landwirtschaftliche nutzung der
landschaft alle bäume und sträucher die
normalerweise die felder umgeben werden
beseitigt es gibt also nur noch einfache
kalefelder die mit synthetischem dünger
und pestiziden behandelt werden vor
allem die neuen insektizide die in den
letzten 20 jahren entwickelt wurden
seien besonders schädlich doch genau
diese werden routinemäßig eingesetzt und
verbleiben dann auch in der umwelt
einige arten wie etwa eine bestimmte
hummel art in den usa können sich
anpassen
doch die zunahme dieser wenigen arten
könne den rückgang der aussterbenden
arten längst nicht kompensieren so die
studie
lediglich eine ökologische form der
landwirtschaft könne dem großen insekten
sterben noch entgegen wirken auch andere
experten und expertinnen die nicht an
der aktuellen studie beteiligt waren
werden den rückgang der insekten als ein
dramatisches problem doch sehen sie
neben dem einsatz der pestizide auch
noch andere faktoren die dazu beitragen
beispielsweise seien die globale
erwärmung und auch die
lichtverschmutzung in diesem
zusammenhang nicht zu unterschätzen
warum die insekten sterben noch mal eine
umfassende dokument draufklicken und das
video ansehen
eine doku vom bayerischen rundfunk also
richtig geil bis dann bleibt dran